สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุก
คนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ค่ะครูหญิงสบายดีมั้ยคะครูหญิงสบายดีค่ะ
ครู
เอ๋
ใช่ครูเอ๋สบายดีมคะสบายดี
ค่ะนักเรียนล่ะคะนักเรียนทุกคนสบายดีมั้ย
คะ
โอนักเรียนเนี่ยบอกสบายดีออสบายดีนะคะครู
หญิงวันนี้วันนี้โหเรามีนักเรียนโอ 1  2
3  4  5  6  7  8  8  9 โอ 10 คน
อ้อเรามีนักเรียน 10 คนหรอคะครู
เอ๋ขอบคุณค่ะใช่ตอนนี้มีนักเรียน 10 คนอ
เอ๊ะมีนักเรียน
ใหม่ 1 คนค่ะอ๋อนักเรียนใหม่เป็นผู้หญิง
เอ้ยไม่ใช่เป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้หญิงคะครูเอ๋
นักเรียนใหม่เป็นผู้ชายโอเป็นผู้ชายนัก
เรียนชื่ออะไรคะสวัสดีค่ะชื่ออะไรคะอ๋อมี
กระดาษมั้ยคะแล้วก็
ปากกาเขียนชื่อให้
ครูนะคะดูอือ๋อนักเรียนเขียนแล้วอะไรนะคะ
k
l
a
u  s
อ้านักเรียนชื่อคุณอะไรคะคุณคอสอ๋อไม่ใช่
คาอัสนะหรือว่าคุณเสคุณเสคุณคอสอ่า
อ้าอนเรบอกโอเคโอเคอะไรก็ได้อะไรก็ได้
เอ๊ะนามสกุลบอกครูได้มั้ยคะออนักเรียนบอก
ออนักนักนักเรียนใส่หัวค่ะอ๋อโอเคโอเค
โอเคมั้ยคุไม่บอกโอเคค่ะอ่าแต่รู้จักชื่อ
เนาะคุณคาสนะคะใช่นะคะก็มีคุณเานักเรียน
ใหม่นะคะอื
เย้ดีใจนะคะค่ะก็คุณเค้ามีพี่ๆนะคะพี่ๆๆๆ
9 คนนะคะค่ะคุณเ้าเป็นน้องนักเรียนใหม่
นะคะค่ะครูหญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้
วันพฤหัสค่ะ
ค่ะวันนี้วันพฤหัสดีวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
ที่ 17 ค่ะวันที่ 17 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือน
มีนาคมปีที่เท่าไหร่แล้วคะปีพ.ศ
256  5 ค่ะอพ.ศ 2  565 ปีค.ศเท่าไหร่คะ
2022 ค่ะอค.ศ 20  22 นะคะออตอนนี้เวลาอ
นาฬิกาไม่
มีเวลาเวลากี่
โมงตอนนี้เวลา
15 น 4
นาทีค่ะครูเอ๋เวลา
1545 นนะคะค่ะ
เอ
หครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋จะนอนแล้วเหรอคะเอ้อครูเอ๋
หาวครูเอ๋ง่วง
นอน
ทำไมไม่ได้ไม่ได้เมื่อคือ
เมื่อคืนเนี่ยตอนกลางคืนครูเอ๋เนี่ยนอน
กี่โมงอโอเมื่อคืนเมื่อคืนครูเอ๋
นอน 22:00 น
อครูเอ๋นอน 22:00 นค่ะโแล้วแล้วก็เยืนะ
นอน 2200 นครูเอกก็นอนๆๆแล้วครูเอกก็ตื่น
ตื่นเที่ยง
คืนเดี๋ยวเขียนยังไงคะ
เนี่ยนี่เนาะใช่เที่ยงคืนอืแล้วครูเอ๋กก็
อาบน้ำ
ค่ะอาบน้ำโอ้ยแชมพูอ่าสบู่อาบน้ำอืมอาบ
น้ำนั่นๆล่ามีมีน้ำใช่มั้น้ำอันนี้น้ำ
เป็นขวดมีผู้หญิงวาดฝักบัวได้มั้ยครูอ่ะ
ครู
เอ๋ักบัวอ้านี่ค่ะักบัวอืครูเอ๋กก็อาบน้ำ
ใช่มั้ยคะอาบน้ำอาบน้ำครูเอกก็เลยตื่น
ตื่นไม่นอนเหรอคะนอนค่ะอ๋อปเอตื่นแล้วก็
ตึ๊กๆๆ
อ่าบ
ประมาณ 1:00 นนะคะ
1:00 ครูเอ๋ก็ไปนอนครั้งที่ 2 อ๋ออันนี้
นอนครั้งที่ 1 นี่ครั้งที่ 2 ก็เลยแล้วก็
นอนแล้วก็
ตื่นกี่โมง
อ่า 6:00 น
ค่ะตื่น 6:00 นแต่นอนตื่นขึ้นมาแล้ว
เอออเอ้อไม่สบายเปวด
หัว
อรู้สึกปวด
อปวดหัว
อืวันนี้ครูเอ๋อ้อยปวดหัวออครูเอ๋ก็เลย
โง่วงหน่อ
ออครูเอ๋นอนมากๆปวดหัวเครูหญิงก็คิดเอ๊ะ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยนอนมากๆทำไมม่่วงนอนถ้าครูเอ๋
นอนมากๆครูเอ๋จะเฮ้อง่วงนอนแล้วก็เอ้อ
ปวดหัวอืถ้าครูเอ๋นอน 4 ชม 5
ชมนิดหน่อย
โอ้แข็งแรงตื่น
อ๋อเมื่อวานนอนมาก
เอ้อปวดหัวนะคะอืค่ะออนอน 4 ชม 5 ชมงโอเค
อืนอนมากก็เลยโอ๊ยปวดหัวแล้วครูหญิงล่ะ
เมื่อวานนอนกี่
โมงครูหญิงนอน 22:00 นค่ะอ้อครูหญิงนอน
22:00 นนะคะ
โอเท่าครูเอ๋ออ้าเวลาเหมือนกันนะนอน 22:00
นอ๋ออ้ายังไม่ถามตื่นอ่าอยากรู้นักเรียน
อือันนั้นครูหญิงใช่มั้ยคะนอนนอนครูหญิง
ต้องครูหญิงไปนอนใช่มอ่าอ่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋
แชร์สกรีนนิดนึงนะคะได้ค่ะโอครูหญิงครูเอ
ต้องลบ
ก่อนได้ค่ะครูเอ๋วาดดอก
บัวปูบอ่าอ
โอเคภูเออ๋อยากรู้นี่อ่ะอันนี้ห้องนอน
ห้องนอนมีอะไรบ้างคะครูหญิงห้องนอนมี
เตียงนอนเตียงนอนนะคะ
มีมีหมอนหมอนนะคะมีอะไรคะอันนี้มีผ้าห่ม
อ่าผ้าห่มนะคะทีนี้เนี่ยอยากจะรู้นัก
เรียน
เนี่ย
ไป
นอนกี่โมงออใช่มั้ยคะอ่ากี่โมงนักเรียนไป
นอนกี่โมงอืครูเอ๋อยากรู้นะอ่าครูหญิงไป
นอนกี่โมงนะคะครูหญิงไป
นอน 22:00 นค่ะอ่าครูหญิงไปนอน 22:00 น
ครูเอ๋ไปนอน 2200 นนะคะอื
เอ๊ครูหญิงอยากจะรู้นักเรียนคนไหนคะไปนอน
กี่โมงอยากรู้นักเรียนใหม่ค่ะอ๋อคุณ
เ้าครูหญิงคุณเคล้ามาวันที่ 1 ออไม่ไม่
ได้เหรอคุณเค้าฟังก่อน
อ่าโอเคองั้นจริๆคุณเค้าบอกโอเคโอเคออคุณ
เค้าบอกโอเคเหรอโอเค
อคุณเคล้าคะคุณเค้าไปนอนกี่โมงคะ
อื
อ๋อคุณเคล้าบอกว่าไป
นอน 23 นออคุณเ้าไปนอน
23 น 23 นนะคะ 23 นผู้หญิงครูเอ๋อยากรู้
คุณ
โรเบิร์ตคุณโรเบิร์ตไปนอนกี่โมงคะออคุณ
โรเบิร์ตบอกว่าคุณโรเบิร์ตไป
นอนเที่ยงครึ่งโอไปนอนเที่ยงคืปึ๊บครึ่ง
ออบเที่ยงครึ่งเที่ยงึ่งครครูเอ๋อ่ะครู
เอ๋อยากรู้ใครดู
ก่อนคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณโรเบิร์ตอยากรู้ใครไป
นอนกี่โมง
อ๋อคุณโรเบิร์ตบอกว่าอยากจะรู้คุณปาวีนา
ไปนอนกี่
โมงคุณประวีนาไปนอนนอนอ้อ
นคุณปาวีนาไปนอนกี่โมงนะคะคุณปาวินาไปนอน
23:30 นค่ะอคุณ
ปาวินาคุณปวนาเลือกค่ะใครอยากรู้ใคร
ใช่คุณปวนาบอกว่าอยากจะรู้คุณเฮีไปนอนกี่
โมง
อ้าคุณเทีบอกแล้วบอกว่าไปนอนกี่โมงคะครู
หญิงคุณเทีบอกว่าไปนอนต 1 ต
หูคุณเฮีนอนดึกใช่มนอนดึกมากนะคโอเคคุณ
เทีคะคุณเทเฮีอยากรู้ใครไปนอนกี่โมงเลือก
ค่ะครูหญิงคุณเทีเลือกใครอ้อคุณเทีบอกว่า
อยากรู้คุณแคทไปนอนกี่โมงออคุณแคทนะคะคุณ
แคทขาคุณแคทไปนอนกี่โมงคะออคุณแคทบอกแล้ว
ครูหญิงคุณแคทไปนอนกี่โมงคะคุณแคทไปนอน
21:30 น
โอหคุณแคทนอนเร็วใช่มะโอ้คุณ
แทฮีนอน
ดึกคุณแคทนอนเร็วใช่มั้ยคะนอนเร็วอใช่อ
คุณแคทขาคุณแคทอยากจะรู้ใครไปนอนกี่โมงคะ
อืผู้หญิงดูคุณแคทหน่อยคุณแคทเลือกใครอ๋อ
คุณแคทเลือกคุณจอห์นจอห์ไหนคะมีจอห์น
อเมริกาจอห์สวีเดนคุณแคทบอกจหอเมริกาอ๋อ
จอห์เท็กซัสเหมือนกันใช่คุณจอห์คะคุณจอห์
ไปนอนกี่โมงคะอ้อคุณคุณจรบอกแล้วค่ะครู
เอ๋บอกว่าไปนอนกี่โมงคะออคุณจอห์ไปนอน
22:30 นค่ะอูคุณจอห์ไปนอน 22 ทครึ่งใช่ม
22:00 นปุ๊บๆเห็นมือครูเอมั้ย 22 นค่ะ
ครึ่งนะอันนี้ครึ่งนะอค่ะใช่คุณจอห์คุณ
จอห์อยากจะรู้ใคร
ไปนอนกี่โมงอ้อคุณจอห์นบอกว่าอยากรู้คุณ
จอห์น
สวีเดนคุณจอห์อยากรู้จอห์ไม่ใช่นะไม่ใช่
จอห์สวีเดนค่ะครูเอ๋คุณจอห์เท็กซัสอยากจะ
รู้คุณจอห์นสวีเดนไปนอนกี่โมงอ่าคุณจอห์
สวีเดนยกแล้วค่ะออคุณจอห์สวีเดนยกกระดาษ
ขึ้น
มากี่โมงคะครูหญิงคุณจอห์สวีเดนไปนอนกี่
โมงคุณจอห์สวีเดนไป
นอน 2 ต 2
โอ
หดึกมากโมากยาวเลยมากกว่าคุณแตฮีมยคะใช่
คุณแตฮีีไปนอน 1:00 นนอนดึกแต่คุณจอห์น
สวีเดนไปนอน 2:00 นดึกมาก
โอดึกมากนะคะโอ
เอ๊คุณจอหสวีเดนอยากรู้ใครไปนอนกี่โมงคะ
เรือกอคุณจอหบอกว่าอยากรู้คุณลิซ่าอ๋อคุณ
ลิซ่าคุณคุลิซ่าขาคุณลิซ่าผู้หญิงครูเอ๋
พูดเพราะๆค่ะคุณลิซ่าขาไปนอนกี่โมงคะอ้อ
คุณลิซ่าบอกแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋คุณลิซ่าบอกว่า
ไปนอนกี่โมงคะครูหญิงครุลิซ่าบอกว่าไปนอน
ออ 22:00 น 22 นอื
ออ้เหมือนคุณครูหญิงเหมือนครูเอ๋นะคะอ๋อ
คุณลิซ่า 22:00 นค่ะคุณลิซ่ามีมีใครให้
เลือกอีกอ๋อมีอีก 2 คนคุณลิซ่าคะคุณลิซ่า
อยากจะรู้ใครไปนอนกี่
โมงคุณลิซ่าอยากรู้คุณ
ธาดาค่ะออคุณาช
อ่าคุณาชขา
ไปนอนกี่โมงคะออคุณาชบอกแล้วค่ะครูเอู๋
เอ๋เห็นแล้วออครูเอ๋รู้รู้แล้วใช่มยเห็น
แล้วคุณทาชิยกมายก
กระดาษครูเอ๋คุณทาดาชิบอกว่าไปนอนกี่โมง
คะคุณทาดาชิ
โอคุณชิบอกว่าไปนอน
3 ค่ะครู
หญิง
โอ้โหเป็นยังไงคะครูเอ๋
แชมเปี้ยนนอนแชมเปี้ยนคุณแตฮี
นอน 1 นนอนดึกค่ะคุณจอห์นอน 2:00 นนอนดึก
มากคุณทาดาชินอน 3:00
นพูดอะไร
นอนดึกมั้ยนอนดึกมากๆๆๆๆๆๆๆ
ๆแล้วก็นอนดึกนอนดึกมากนอนดึก
มามากๆๆค่ะอันนี้คุณธาดาิโหคุณธาดาินอน
ดึกมากค่ะคุณราชิอยากจะรู้ว่าใครนอนกี่
โมงค
คุณคุณซิบอกคุณ
แบรดคุณ
[เพลง]
แบดคุณแบดนอนกี่โมงคะครูหญิงคุณแบรดบอก
แล้วค่ะยกกระดาษแล้ว
อืกี่โมงอ่ะกุเอ๋มองไม่เห็นคุณแบรดบอกว่า
คุณแบรดไปนอนเที่ยงคืนค่ะออเที่ยงคืน
นะคะอเที่ยงคืนเที่ยงคืนอ้าโอเคครบ 10 คน
ใช่มั้ยคะครบแล้วค่ะอ 1  2  3  4  5  6  7
8  9  10 ครบแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋คนนะคะอ๋อเรา
รู้นักเรียนไปนอนกี่โมงค่ะต่อไปครูหญิง
ครูเออยากรู้อีกอยากรู้อะไรก็ครูหญิงถาม
ครูเอ๋นอนแล้วตื่นใช่่มตื่นกี่โมงอครูเอ๋
ตื่น 6:00 นใช่มั้ยใช่ๆครูเอ๋เนี่ยวันนี้
นะวัน
นี้ 1800 นอ่ะครูเอ๋ตื่น 6:00 นนะคะค่ะ
ครูหญิงนอนนอนกี่โมงนะครูหญิงนอน 22:00 น
อ่าแล้วตื่นกี่โมงคะตื่น 7 นค่ะผู้หญิง
นอน 22:00 นตื่น 7:00 นค่ะผู้หญิงนอน
นานกี่ชั่วโมงโอครูหญิงนอน 22:00 น 23 น
เที่ยงคื 1  2  3  4  5:00  1800 น 7 น 9
ช่วโมงอู้ครูหญิงนอนนาน 9 ช่วโมง
ออดีค่ะดีมากแข็งแรงแข็งแรงอืเอ่อครูหญิง
คะคะเอ่อครูเอ๋อยากรู้คุณเค้าคุณเค้าขา
คุณเค้าไปนอน 10 เอ่อ 5 นใช่ม 23:00 น
23:00 นคุณเค้าตื่นกี่โมงคะคุณเคล้าบอก
ว่าคุณเคล้าตื่นต 5
นตื่น 5:00 นผู้หญิงคเตื่น 23 นถึง 5:00
นคุณเคล้านอนทั้งหมดกี่
ชั่วโมง 23 นเที่ยง 1  2:00  3:00  4 น 5
6 ชมงค่ะโอ้คุณเคล้านอน 6 ชมงอืนะคะ 6
ชมงอค่ะต่อไปใครคะครูหญิงคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ
โรเบิร์ตคะคุณ
โรเบิร์ตนอนแล้วตื่นกี่โมงคะอ่าคุณ
โรเบิร์ตบอกว่าตื่น 800
น 800 นอ๋อคุณโรเบิร์ตก็นอนทั้งหมด 7 ชม
ครึ่งใช่มั้ยคะอใช่ค่ะครู
เอ๋คุณโรเบิร์ตนอน 7 ชมครึ่งนอ่ะให้นัก
เรียนดูอ่า 7 ชมึ่งนะคะคุณโรเบิร์ตอ่าต่อ
ไปใครคะคุณปวีนาใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงถาม
คุณประวีนาบ้างคุณประวีนา
นอนตื่นกี่โมงคะออออคุณปวีนาบอกครูหญิง
ว่าตื่นกี่โมงคะคุณปาวิดาบอกตื่น 7:30 น
ค่ะคุณประวีนาตื่น 7:30 นค่ะู้หญิงคุณ
ประวีนา
นอนทั้งหมดกี่ชั่วโมงอเที่ยงเ่อ 5:00 น
ไม่ใช่ 2300 น 23 น 23:30
น 123
เอ่ะเที่ยง 0  130 น 230  330  430 น 5:30
น 6:30 น 7:30 น 8 ชมง
อคุณประวีนา
นอนนาน 8 ชมนะคะอแล้วคุณเทีนะคะครูหญิง
คุณเทีคะคุณเทีตื่นกี่โมงคะออคุณเทีตื่น 9
นค่ะครูเอ๋คุณเทีตื่น 900 นอืโอคุณเท
นอน 1 ค่ะแล้วก็
ตื่น 9:00 นอ่าคุณเทีนอนต1นอนแล้วก็ตื่น
99:00 นคุณเฮีนอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงคะคุณเที
นอนนานอันนี้ 8 ชมงค่ะอืคุณเทีนอนนาน 8
ชมง 8 ชมงต่อไปค่ะคุณแคทค่ะคะคุณแคทตื่น
กี่โมงคะ
อ้อคุณแคทบอกว่าคุณแคทตื่น 700
นคุณแคทตื่น 700 นอื
โอ 7:00 นคุณแคทนอนทั้งหมดกี่ชั่วโมง
เดี๋ยวครูเอกคิดก่อนคิดคิด 21:30 น 22:30
น 23:30 น 22:30 น 23:30 น
1230  130
230  330  430 น 5:30 น 6:30 นตื่นกี่
โมงนะคะตื่น 7:00 น
ค่ะ 9 ชม 0 หู
อูคุณตอนนี้คุณแคทนอนมากที่สุดเนาะใช่ค่ะ
คุณแคทนอนนาน 9 ชมครึ่ง
ค่ะต่อไปค่ะคุณคุณจคุณจอห์เท็กซัสนะคะคุณ
จอห์เท็กซัสคุณจอห์นอนแล้วก็ตื่นกี่โมงคะ
ออคุณจอห์นบอกว่าตื่น 4:00 นค่ะครู
เอ๋ตื่น 4:00 นคุณจอห์ตื่น 4:00 นคุณจอห์
น้องนอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงครูหญิงคุณจรนอน
22:30 น 5  6  1  2
3  5 ชมครึ่งเหรอคะใช่
ค่ะคุณจอห์เทกซัสนอนนาน 5 ชมครึ่งค่ะ 5
ชวมครึเดี๋ยวๆๆดูก่อนดูก่อนตอนนี้ตอนนี้
ใครนอนน้อยที่สุด
คะน้อยที่สุดโอ้คุณจอห์เทกซัสค่ะ 5 ชมง
ครึ่งอ๋อคุณจอห์นเท็กซัสนอนน้อยที่สุดใคร
นอนมากที่สุดคุณแคทค่ะคุณแคทอ๋อคุณแคทนอน
กี่ชั่วโมงคะคุณแคทนอน 9 ชมครึ่งค่ะโอ้
คุณแคทก็นอนมากที่สุดคุณจอนอนน้อยที่สุด
ค่ะอ่ะต่อไปค่ะใครเอ่ยคุณจอห์สวีเดนคุณ
จอห์สวีเดนคะคุณจอห์ตื่นใช่มนอนแล้วก็
ตื่นกี่โมงคะออคุณจอห์บอกว่าคุณจอห์ตื่น 8
นชค่ะคุณจอห์ตื่น 8:00
นค่ะอองั้นคุณจอห์นอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงคุณ
จอห์นอนนานคุณจรนอน 2  3  4 น 5:00  6:00
น 7 น 8 น 6 ชมงค่ะครูเอ๋คุณจอนอน 6 ชมนะ
คะแข็งแรง 6 ช่มอือ่ะคุณลิซ่าขาต่อไปคุณ
ลิซ่านะคะคุณลิซ่าตื่นกี่โมงคะอ้าผู้หญิง
คุณลิซ่าคุณลิซ่าบอกว่าอะไรครุณลิซ่าบอก
ว่าตื่น 6 นออคุณซัหาะตื่น 6:00 นงั้นคุณ
ลิซ่านอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงคะโอ้ 22:00 น 23:00
นเที่ยง 1  2:00  3  4  5:00  18:00 น 8
ชมงค่ะครูเอ๋คุณลิซ่านอนนาน 8 ชมงอืค่ะ
โอ้ดีค่ะดีอืคุณธาดาิคุณธาดาิตื่นกี่โมง
คะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋เห็นมยอ๋อครูเอ๋เห็นค่ะคุณ
ธชนอน
ตื่น 8
น 8 นอค่ะคุณาชินอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงคะคุณ
ราชินอน 3:00 ใช่มย 3:00 ก็ 4 น 5  600 น
7 น 8 นออคุณชินอนนาน 5 ชมงอะไร 5 โอ
เป็น
แชมป์นอนนกที่สุดอแชมเปี้ยนนอนน้อยนะคะ
ออโอเคอ่ะคนสุดท้ายคุณแบรดนะคุณแบรดคุณ
แบรดบอกว่าคุณแบรดตื่น 6 นค่ะออตื่น 6:00
[เพลง]
นงั้นคุณแบทนอนนานกี่ชั่วโมงคะคุณแบดนอน
นาน 6 ชมงค่ะคุณแบทนอนนาน 6  6 ชมครูหญิง
คะใครนอนมากที่
สุดคุณแคทนอนมากที่สุดค่ะคุณแคทนอนทั้ง
หมดกี่ชั่วโมงคุณแคทนอนทั้ง
หมด 9 ชมงครึ่งออคุณแคทนอน 9 ชมครึ่งหรือ
บางทีพูดนอนนาน 9 ชมครึ่ง
โอคใครนอน
น้อยที่
สุดคุณทาดาชิค่ะคุณ
ธารชะอม
คุณ
ธาราชัย
นอน 5 ชมงอใคร
นอนเร็วที่สุดนอนเร็วที่สุดคุณแคทค่ะอ้อ
คุณแคทนอนเร็วนอนกี่โมงนอน 21:30 นอ๋อคุณ
แคทไปนอน 21:30 นค่ะใครนอนดึกที่
สุดคุณทาดาชิค่ะโอ้คุณทาดาชิมี 2
แชมเปี้ยนเหรอคะอ่ะคุณแคทก็มี 2
แชมเปี้ยนอ๋อโอเคคุณทาชินอนดึกที่สุดแล้ว
ก็นอนน้อยที่สุดใช่ค่ะคุณแคทนอนเร็วที่
สุดแล้วก็นอนนานที่สุดอ่าใช่ค่ะใครนอน
เวลาเหมือนกันอ๋อมีครูเอ๋ครูหญิงคุณ
ลิซ่านอนเวลาเหมือนกันนอนกี่โมงคะนอน 4
22:00 นค่ะนอน 22:00 นนะคะโอเคคนอื่นมี
มั้ยนอนเวลาเหมือนกันเอ่อมี
คุณมีมั้ยคะไม่มีแล้วค่ะไม่มีไม่มีนะคะ
โอเคงั้นใครนอน
อ่านานเท่ากันอ้า
มีคุณประวีนา
คุณแฮีคุณลิซ่าอ่ะนอนหึให้ดูได้มั้ยคะได้
ค่ะคุณคุณ
ประวินานอน 8 ชมงค่ะคุณแตฮี
นอน 8
ชมงแล้วก็คุณลิซ่าคุณลิซ่านอน 8 ชมเท่า
กันใช่ค่ะเอ๊เห็นคุณจอ
ใช่ๆคุณ
จอห์คุณจอห์นอน 6 ชมแล้วก็คุณเคล้าคุณ
เคล้าก็นอน 6 ชมงเท่ากันนะคะใช่ค่ะเท่า
กันอืใครตืูเอ๋ลืมค่ะขอโทษค่ะคุณแบรดด้วย
คุณแบรดนอน 6
ชมงเท่ากันนะคะใช่ครูหญิงใครตื่นเร็วที่
สุด
อืตื่นเร็วคุณจอห์เท็กซัสค่ะ
ออตื่นต 4:00 นนะคะตื่นเร็วนะคะใครตื่น
สายที่สุดใครตื่นอ้าคุณแตฮีค่ะคุณแตฮี
ตื่นกี่โมงคะคุณแตฮีตื่น 9 นอ๋อตื่นสายนะ
คะตื่นสายหรือตื่นช้าโอเคโอเคตื่นสายโอเค
ตื่นช้าโอเคนะคะใช่ค่ะมีอะไรอีกครูหญิง
อยากรู้อะไรครูหญิงอยากรู้ครูเอ๋นอนกี่
ชั่วโมงต้องตัด 1 ชมมใช่มั้ยอ่อเมื่อวาน
ครูเอ๋นอน
ก็ 23 น
เยืตึ๊ๆ 2:00 น 3:00  400  5:00 น 600 น 7
น 8 ชมมั้ยครูเอู๋เอ๋นอน 7 ชมสิพคุณลิซ่า
นอน 22:00 นตื่น 18:00 น 8 ชมอ๋อใช่ๆนอน
22:00 นตื่น 18:00 นแต่เบรค 1 ชม 7 ชมง
ใช่มั้ยคะอูเอ๋นอน 7 ชมงค่ะ 7 ชั่วมงครู
เอกง่วงนอนอืครูหญิงนอน 9
ชั่วโมง
สบายสบายใช่ครูเอกง่วงนอนแล้วครูหญิงใช่
เพราะว่าตอนนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้วให้ครูเอ๋
เนี่ยไปนอน
เพราะว่าถ้าครูเอ๋หาวฮ้อหาวมากๆเดี๋ยวนัก
เรียนนักเรียนก็จะหาวนะคะงั้นครูเอ๋บ๊าย
บายนะคะไปนอนนะคะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊าย
บาย